now it's two years to the day since the
world health organization set up an
emergency crisis team in response to an
outbreak of unusual pneumonia cases in
the city of wuhan china now that was one
day after chinese authorities alerted
the who to a cluster of cases in the
city
beijing says the novel coronavirus can
be traced back to this live food market
in wuhan the subsequent outbreak turned
the world upside down going on to infect
at least
million people killing more than 5
million and disrupting everyday life
across the planet
and when will it all end joining me now
to break that down is dw reporter
matthew moore thanks for joining us
do we know when this pandemic is going
to be over yeah that's the the million
dollar question isn't it um and that's
the question at this that that's at the
heart of a really heated debate in
science circles at the moment
on the one side of this you have
scientists like those at the university
college london who say we need to
prepare to move from a pandemic phase to
an endemic phase and what they mean is
that we should be thinking about
dropping restrictions and accepting that
people will get infected and you cannot
avoid it but you will and you can avoid
serious sickness by getting vaccinated
now that also means that the virus is in
circulation and that you accept a
constant level of death to put it
carelessly
but you accept that and governments can
manage that because they know what they
will get with it and they can avoid
excessive sickness at work and hospital
becoming strained
and the reason they're optimistic about
that is they say there's a high level of
natural immunity in the uk at the moment
because of
so many people have been infected and
they also have a high vaccinated rate
but what this endemic phase means is
that you have to countries have to
decide how much
how many casualties and how much death
they're willing to accept and obviously
that will
differ from country to country
so if that's what british experts are
saying what's the situation here in
germany for example yeah well germany
is a different situation because one of
germany's leading virologists is is all
optimistic although cautiously it has to
be said about where germany will find
itself in 2022
christian dawson christian drosten i
should say says data from omicron shows
that it is less dangerous than first
feared so he's he's happy about that and
that gives him cause for optimism but
germany says we'll face a rough start
because germany unlike the uk hasn't had
as many infections so has the lower
natural immunity and has a lower
vaccinated rate let's listen to what he
had to say
if we look at the major industrialized
countries of europe germany has the
highest percentage of people who haven't
been exposed to the virus and who
haven't been vaccinated and we don't
know what that means for us
even if the disease severity is bearable
for the vaccinated which seems to be the
case we still have to worry about a
large section of the population and that
will certainly have a
all right well we will see what happens
hopefully the new year will be a better
one than last year matthew moore thanks
so much
you